rain is expected to continue into the
weekend across an already flood ravaged
California flash flooding and mudslides
have washed out several roads across the
state and in some cases drivers had to
be rescued from cars stranded in high
water mola Lengai is in Sausalito near
San Francisco where a mudslide destroyed
two homes
Mulla good morning good morning dozens
of homes in this hillside neighborhood
are still evacuated and people here are
understandably still on edge as rain
continued to fall overnight and they've
already seen the damage it can do
yesterday's mudslide caused this pile of
debris trapping a woman for at least an
hour
firefighters combed through a mountain
of rubble to find 76 year-old Susan
Gordon trapped up to her neck in mud
Rosaleen Bulger's saw the rescue they
were doing all that they can there's a
lot of debris around
Gordon suffered minor injuries after a
hillside crumbled Thursday lifting the
home she was in off its foundation and
sending it hurtling down the hill 75
feet waiting to see if that hillside is
structurally sound and to find out when
we can go back torrential rain and heavy
winds battered the state officials are
keeping a close eye on a levee that is
breached in a rural part of Northern
California huge tree camped out in
Southern California the same system also
brought down large trees and left
waterlogged hillsides at risk after more
than two days of rain this small cliff
gave way along with part of this home in
some mountain communities transportation
officials urged residents to shelter in
place after large chunks of road washed
away desert areas were affected - rising
floodwaters also left drivers trapped
and forced several rescues it's not just
the water but the debris and the rocks
and the trees that can cause a lot of
damage this storm is also creating chaos
in the Sierra Nevada mountains where
nearly a thousand lightning strikes were
recorded yesterday and nearly seven feet
of snow expected through the weekend
here in the Bay Area the rains expected
to contain
you into early next week Gail molar
thank you very much